Hello there my name is Carlos Renaso.
I am the writer/director of ¡CALAMBRE!, my
debut feature film about a poet who returns
to New York City to rekindle an old flame
only to realize that she’s moved on.
It’s currently streaming online for as little
as $2.99.
Today I want to share five tips with you for
making a no budget movie.
BUDGET
We’ll start off with the budget.
Now it varies a bit when you talk to filmmakers
in terms of their process.
Do you consider the budget or the story first?
Me, I like to go with the budget because you
can build your story around it.
Whatever resources are available to you, you
can use it to begin writing.
Now our film ¡CALAMBRE!
Came a little under $6,000 to get it in the
can.
But we didn’t have the entire $6,000 at
our disposal when we first started shooting.
That’s something that really hurt us and
set us back from shooting.
We had to pay actors and lockdown locations
but we couldn’t do that since we were shooting
and paying for everything as we worked our
day jobs and shot check-to-check.
It may seem like the obvious thing to have
all the money up front but not to an eager
filmmaker like me who is just so eager to
finish his first film.
STORY
You’ve raised the money, now it’s time
to write the story.
What kind of story do you write?
I suggest keeping it simple for comedy or
drama.
For horror or thriller you might need more
money in time for continuity and special effects.
But for comedy or drama your biggest worry
is going to be the dialogue and the performances
things that as a director are much more manageable
for you.
Our film ¡CALAMBRE! relies heavily on dialogue
and what that allowed me to do was make it
like a hangout movie where people have moments
of disappointment, where they argue, they
laugh or serious moments.
Now one thing you have to be careful of is
the number of characters you have in your
story.
The more you have, the more of a concern it’s
going to be later when scheduling actors to
shoot.
¡CALAMBRE!
Has 6 characters in it and that gave me a
lot of trouble because people work and have
their personal lives as well.
So I suggest having three characters at the
most for your story.
Great examples of this would be Richard Linklater’s
TAPE and Christopher Nolan’s first moving
FOLLOWING.
LOCATION
Location, location, it’s all about location.
As you write your story your visual world
will take place.
Ideally you want a location that is easily
accessible to you via your bedroom or your
parent’s house.
But if you don’t have those things you might
have to pay.
For ¡CALAMBRE! we needed a bar.
So we rented out a studio.
But the studio presented us with a big issue
- sound.
The studio was located in an industrial area
so there were a lot of trucks outside loading
and unloading.
So it was definitely disruptive.
Then down the hall there was a big wedding
rehearsal going on.
You can imagine the nightmare that that was.
My suggestion is always scout the location
beforehand.
If you’re renting out a place, make sure
to ask if your crew members will be the only
ones there on shoot day.
TRUST
This is a big one.
Film is a collaborative medium and unless
you’re a jack-of-all-trades and can do everything
yourself you’re going to need help whether
it’s the sound recordist, cinematographer,
sound mixer.
Be careful who you trust with your film.
I hired a sound mixer.
The person took three months to polish up
the sound on ¡CALAMBRE! which is ridiculous
because ¡CALAMBRE! is only 52 minutes long.
He missed deadlines because of a personal
issue but then it would happen again and again.
He finally revealed he had taken on another
job just keeping really busy.
How do you avoid this from happening?
Before you hire a sound mixer talk with their
references.
Interview potential candidates if possible.
Give the reasonable strict deadlines and also
tell them not to take on any other jobs if
they’ve taken on your project (especially
when you’ve already paid them).
FILM FESTIVALS
You finish your film, now you’re ready to
present it to the world.
What kind of film festivals do you submit
it to?
Local festivals, international festivals?
One this is certain you’ve got to have a
plan about your submissions.
I don’t submit to festivals that require
more than $50.00.
And even at $50.00, make sure that festival
caters to your kind of film.
You probably shouldn’t submit a comedy in
to a horror film festival.
Secondly, seek out festivals that are in their
first or second year of running.
These festivals may be a little bit more receptive
to no budget movies than the bigger, established
film festivals.
There are even festivals that do online screenings
which may be beneficial to your film.
Lastly, keep in mind these festivals require
your money to run so be very selective in
your submission process.
And there you have it.
No go make your film and remember, once you’ve
made your film no one can take that away from
you.
My name is Carlos Renaso.
Check out my film ¡CALAMBRE! streaming online.
Peace!